[Music]
on this Saturday night Airlines aim for
a full roster on planes
WestJet and Air Canada are removing seat
distancing the people get on planes and
come away getting sick
no one will fly the health fears that
are taking off the protection measures
the travel industry is putting in place
to woo back tourists plus the pressure
on Ottawa to sanction China here we're
talking about the new global bully will
this strategy help get the to Michael's
home
and the Simpsons role reversal hello
welcome to the pretty much white actors
will no longer play ethnic parts
Wabble national would Robin Gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we've heard over and over again the
importance of staying two meters apart
to slow the spread of kovat 19 but
tonight Canada's two biggest airlines
are bucking that advice as they attempt
to recover from the devastating losses
caused by the pandemic WestJet and Air
Canada will end their onboard seat
distancing policies next week to try to
fill their planes back up but as Michael
co2 reports some experts say the move
could backfire that physical distancing
passengers have gotten used to an
airport terminals will be gone once you
get onto the plane beginning July 1st
Air Canada and West jet will no longer
block off seats in the cabin instead
they're reverting to the recommendation
from the International Air Transport
Association to end the practice and fill
every seat it's a little too close like
my taste it's especially strangers not
maintaining two meters of space goes
against the advice of Canada's chief
medical officer a spokesperson for
Transport Minister Marc Garneau points
out there are many layers of protection
in air travel including wearing masks on
board and making temperature screening
mandatory for all passengers traveling
to Canada starting July 30th disease
experts say we need to proceed with
caution
Eastern climatic people who tend to
spread the virus probably less than
somebody who stay coughing or sneezing
either way though
whatever we do it has to be met with
ongoing monitoring in a statement Air
Canada pointed to their clean care plus
program as an effective multi-layered
way to keep passengers safe which
includes frequent sanitizing of surfaces
adding quote we intend to continue
evaluating new processes and
technologies as they become available to
further enhance safety the WestJet noted
I add as guidance supports the removal
of seat distancing as protections are
provided in the cabin such as HEPA
filters and the physical barrier of seat
backs
WestJet also underlined how they have
enhanced cleaning the question is will
all that be enough to get people flying
again that's another born issue because
of people that are playing
and come away getting sick no one will
fly Carl more says not selling the
middle seat means airlines aren't making
money in the next few months we'll be
pivotal for the entire industry if this
cannot be solved airlines are going to
go bankrupt and large numbers without a
lot of government support and they're
gonna shrink down tremendously which is
going to have a huge impact on the
Canadian and world economy it's all part
of a careful balance between keeping
kovat 19 in check and helping the
economy take off again
Mike lacouture global news Ottawa many
countries depend on tourism dollars
that's why the European Union will be
loosening restrictions next week on
international travel airlines are trying
to restore confidence with these
specialized cleaning techniques and
equipment our Europe bureau chief
crystal de man singh is looking at
what's being done and crystal experts
the economies may not recover if people
don't start flying again Robin you're
absolutely right all of these things are
connected I'm out here at London City
Airport and it should be busy we should
be watching planes taking off and
landing but people just aren't flying
and they haven't been for months across
Europe there has been a slow reopening
and come July the majority of foreign
tourists will be welcomed back the
passenger is going to have more
responsibilities he's going to have to
be fit for travel which in the past
wasn't necessarily the case but that's
what's going to help us reduce the risk
the International Air Transport
Association has been calling travelers
from 11 countries including Canada for
several months and people are hesitant
when it comes to the question of
returning to travel the majority of
those polled 55% say they'll wait at
least six months before traveling I had
a lot of anxiety around that because I
was like am I making the right choice
traveling Ronnie Sullivan just took a
flight on the 19th back to Toronto from
London within the airport they had Bay's
that they were guiding people towards
and then they had marks on the ground of
maintaining social distance it was kind
of
we are comforting at the same time
screening measures vary from airport and
country but overall the industry is
looking at what's being done in other
sectors and replicating that crowds are
being limited masks and barriers used
and planes are being scrubbed and fought
aviation experts expect confidence we'll
slowly rebuild and more people will
start flying
however the recovery is expected to take
years and all of this is based on there
not being a second wave robin krishna
commencing in london in vancouver health
authorities are warning patrons of a
popular strip club they may have been
exposed to Kovan 19 multiple individuals
who tested positive for the virus
attended Brandis exotic show lounge
between June 21st and June 25th anyone
who visited during those dates is being
asked to monitor themselves for 14 days
health officials say there is no ongoing
risk to the community the strip club is
temporarily closed nuke Ovid 19 cases in
the United States keep going up and up
there were more than 45,000 new cases
reported Friday the highest single day
increase yet that brings the overall
total to about 2.5 million tested cases
since the outbreak began as Jennifer
Johnson reports officials in some of the
biggest states like Texas and Florida
now have to make some tough and
unpopular decisions after scenes like
this Miami's mayor made the unpopular
announcement closing all beaches from
July 3rd to July 7th some of the busiest
days of the summer Florida again
shattered its Daily Record for new cases
almost 9600 people every bar in the
state has been ordered closed after
reopening just three weeks ago
enforcement officers are on patrol a lot
of them been packed and has really been
out of hand
along with Florida for other states
reported their highest ever daily
caseloads
Georgia Idaho Tennessee in Utah
California is facing staggering
increases to its governor has asked
Imperial County on the state's border
with Mexico to reinstate a stay at home
order its infection rate is almost 23
percent if states are not
able to come to some consensus I am
committed to intervening
the Trump administration says things are
on the right path even as cases of Kovan
19 grow in at least 32 states doctors
with the White House coronavirus task
force telling Americans to wear masks
but all week neither Vice President Mike
Pence nor President Donald Trump wore
them in several public appearances pence
at this auto manufacturer in Ohio the
president at this Wisconsin shipyard and
this rally of young Republicans in
hard-hit Arizona pence who travels to
Texas Sunday defended the lack of masks
at those events freedom of speech and
the right to peaceably assemble is
enshrined in the Constitution of the
United States meanwhile the pandemic
continues to crush the economy Wall
Street tanked again Friday Congress may
consider another economic stimulus bill
sometime in July we'll take a snapshot
of where the country stands see how the
jobs are coming back see where we think
we are this comes as a troubling new
watchdog report found a 1.4 billion
dollars of stimulus payments went to
more than a million Americans who were
already dead 35 million Americans are
still awaiting their checks Jennifer
Johnson Global News Washington it's been
one week since the 60 Gerald Ontario man
was shot and killed by police during a
mental health call today protestors
rallied outside Police Headquarters
calling for a public inquiry and for the
officer involved to be fired globals
morgan campbell is watching this story
for us tonight Morgan many have turned
out in support of the chantry family who
just want to understand how a mental
health call turned into a fatality at
the hands appeal Regional Police and to
ensure that it never happens again
[Music]
with placards in hand these men women
and children are demanding justice for a
jazz Chowdhury Choudhary's family called
police when he wasn't taking his
prescribed medication that mental health
call turned deadly police believed the
man who lived with schizophrenia and
didn't speak English had weapons in his
apartment
Chowdhury had also barricaded himself
inside officers breached the back of the
apartment entering via a balcony it was
all caught on video the provinces
Special Investigations Unit the police
watchdog says officers discharged
plastic projectiles and a Taser before
firing on the man investigators know to
weapon was recovered at the scene
protestors say Chad Ray's death at a
time when many are calling for a change
in the way police are funded has once
again highlighted the need for
additional support services for families
and police dealing with mental health
calls you're gonna see a lot of
different communities that have been
impacted by police violence that are
frustrated by a lack of police
accountability and I think people who
have been suffering at the intersection
of mental health and policing for a very
long time as you can see the public
itself is upset if the public rules that
listen what happened was wrong
you have to answer stakeholders are
calling for the firing of the officer
who shot the man and that a public
inquiry be launched as they have little
faith and the SI use ability to conduct
a fair improper investigation prior to
the rally the police chief issued a
statement saying he is committed to
bringing about systemic change including
how police respond to mental health
calls still this group of supporters say
that simply isn't enough Robin Morgan
Campbell in Mississauga tonight
protesters in Toronto took part in an
international demonstration paying
tribute to a 12 yield refugee from
Somalia on the anniversary of her death
in the UK shukla Abdi drowned in a river
near Manchester one year ago organizers
of the Toronto rally say her story
highlights the issue of racial injustice
police initially called her death a
tragic incident their actions are now
part of an independent investigation
Abdi's family claims she was a victim of
bullying at school and that a group of
children were with her before she died
her mother adds it was unlike her to go
near the water because she couldn't swim
a somber day on Vancouver Island as the
remains of a Canadian Forces pilot
killed in a military helicopter crash in
April have finally returned home a
homecoming procession brought the
remains of captain Kevin Hagen to a
funeral home Hagen who would have turned
31 next month was originally from
Nanaimo he was one of six people who
lost their lives when a cyclone
helicopter crashed off the coast of
Greece on April 29th the chopper
encountered trouble while returning to
the Navy frigate HMS CS Fredericton and
went down in the Ionian Sea the federal
government is feeling the pressure from
all sides over the fate of two Canadian
men imprisoned arbitrarily in China last
week a group of former parliamentarians
and senior diplomats urged the Justice
Minister to end extradition proceedings
for huawei executive mung Wong Jo but a
group of senators says the best way for
Canada respond to China is to levy
sanctions joining us to talk about this
is the host of the West block Mercedes
Stevenson Mercedes
Robbin a dozen senators including a
number who were appointed by prime
minister justin trudeau urged ottawa
last week to impose Magnitsky style
sanctions on chinese officials for gross
violations of human rights and
fundamental freedoms including the
imprisonment and charges against michael
SPAWAR and michael khovrakh Magnitsky
style sanctions target powerful regime
officials guilty of human rights abuses
by freezing their foreign assets in
places like canada and banning their
entry to this country in an interview
which will air on the west block
tomorrow i asked one of the senators who
signed the letter asking the government
to do this why she thinks Magnitsky
style sanctions are the way to go with
handling China's communist regime the
Magnitsky law is designed to go after
those who have been abusing human rights
in other countries but give to
themselves the benefits of investing in
Canada so this is something that we can
do with within our control and it also
makes a very strong statement that we're
not only talking about human rights
abuses here we're talking about the new
global bully and they need for Canadians
and Canadian parliamentarians to do what
we can to stand up to the bully we'll
also be talking to the newly named
interim leader of the separatist wex at
Canada Party J Hill he's a surprise name
for many who remember hill from his
Ottawa days when he was the conservative
house leader for Prime Minister Stephen
Harper so why has he gone from a staunch
Federalist to a Western separatist he'll
says it's time for a referendum and to
let the people of Western Canada decide
if they want to stay in Confederation
the anger is so deep-seated and the
frustration with a failed Confederation
is so widespread now in Western Canada
that we are taking this extraordinary
step I believe to organize federally and
candidates hopefully in the next federal
election we'll have more on the show
Robin as well as an interview with
premier Dwight ball of Newfoundland and
Labrador about the deep economic trouble
that province finds itself in as well as
an interview with Michael coffer ex-wife
Vina Najibullah who will join us to talk
about what she wants the government to
do next
to help her husband Robin all right
thanks for that Mercedes and you can
watch it all this Sunday on the West
block with Mercedes Stevenson right here
on global coming up testing wastewater
for kovat 19y researchers believe this
could help doctors trace the disease and
is there a constitutional coup happening
in Russia global national is back in two
minutes
Canadian researchers at the University
of Calgary and Ryerson in Toronto have
begun an unusual study to understand the
path of Cova 19 before there's a second
wave
they're testing wastewater as Mike gelee
reports it's a dirty job that could
establish an early warning system as
kuba 19 spread around the world the
global focus was on finding ways to
contain it but health care professionals
and scientists were already looking
ahead and preparing for the inevitable
second wave I mean there's never been a
pandemic and the history of humankind
where there hasn't been a second wave so
I do think this is all over yet
a Canadian made a pandemic predicting
software called blue dot was able to
predict the original spread of kovat 19
it's AI is monitoring the internet for
signs of that second wave and now
scientists at Ryerson University in
Toronto are set to begin using a far
less pleasant but potentially effective
early warning system the city sewer
system where they can detect the virus
once it's ensuing it's no longer
dangerous to humans but it does give an
indication of how much virus is in the
community and if levels spiked they'll
know the second wave is coming yes it
would be if it works it could give us
like a two or three-week window before
things get bad and if we have a two or
three week window then things will get
bad similar programs have been used
successfully around the world Australia
Iceland the Netherlands and the state of
Utah where scientists were able to warn
authorities of a surge of cases at a
meatpacking plant hey this is coming we
need to be prepared and we need to begin
to understand what might be going on in
the county same things been done in the
Netherlands where six days before the
first clinical case was identifying the
community the signal was found in
similar testing is being done in BC and
several small Ontario communities but
not to the scale plan for Toronto it's
just too much sewage to get accurate
readings so they'll focus on key spa
in the sewage system not the main plant
and so essentially what we're doing then
is we are analyzing waste from a smaller
geographic area we can do that in
multiple places almost like
neighborhoods we could isolate
individual neighborhoods and hopefully
the results make up for the fact the job
stinks microlight global news Toronto
still ahead the referendum in Russia how
fladam important is trying to hang on to
power
you are watching global national this
week Russia pushes ahead with a
referendum on key changes to its
constitution that could keep Vladimir
Putin in power until 2036 the 67 year
old has ruled Russia for over two
decades and as Mike Armstrong explains
critics are calling the pivotal move a
constitutional coup holding a plebiscite
during a pandemic means precautions
polling stations have been set up across
Russia in buses tense even playgrounds
and train stations the referendum was
originally scheduled for April 22nd but
was delayed due to the coronavirus in
the months since the situation in Russia
has only worsened but the vote is going
ahead anyway it's been spread out over
seven days and wraps up July 1st
my first War both husbands as the vote
couldn't be put off any longer the
constitutional changes have to be
settled now Russians are deciding in a
whole series of changes about 200
amendments everything from banning gay
marriage to increasing minimum wage and
pensions but it's a straight up yes or
no vote on the entire bundle and
included in that bundle is one that
would allow Vladimir Putin to run for
president again and again after that so
it's a minor point but a really
important point the big thing is Putin
wants to rule for life which is the
Soviet tradition the ADEA didn't Putin
has held one of the two big jobs in
Russia since 1999 he's gone back and
forth between Prime Minister and
president but under the 1993
Constitution he can't run for president
next time around the amendment would let
him run for two more six-year mandates
by typical sized Kremlin critic Alexei
Navalny calls the referendum a sham and
has been urging Russians not to vote for
the amendments to pass they need 50%
support voter turnout isn't an issue
they just have to hit that 50% threshold
something observers say likely isn't a
problem I mean he's gonna win and if he
doesn't win he'll rig it so he wins
anyway
I mean that's just how they do things in
Russia still now the reason the Kremlin
has pushed ahead with a vote despite the
pandemic may actually be its handling of
the coronavirus living a Putin still
popular but he has taken a hit the goal
may be to get this vote done
before things get worse my carbs from
global news up next The Simpsons get
real about representation in animation
[Music]
The Simpsons is the latest show that's
going back to the drawing board with its
casting hello welcome to the kwik-e-mart
hey chief we could arrest every single
car thief in Springfield you know why
they got us sitting next to each other
because we're the two funniest guys in
our towns that's what was happening
behind the scenes but moving forward the
show's producers say The Simpsons will
no longer have white actors voice
non-white characters there have been
growing calls to address systemic racism
casting a new light on media and
entertainment reckoning Missy Jenny
slate who voices the biracial character
of Missy on Netflix is big mouth series
revealed her own reckoning this week she
says black characters should be played
by black people her move was followed by
two other white actors Mike Henry is
stepping down from his role as Cleveland
on the Fox series Family Guy and Kristen
Bell will no longer voice Molly
for Apple's animation Central Park and
that is global national for this
Saturday I'm Robin Gill we leave you
tonight with pride on Parliament Hill
rainbow flags are paying tribute to
LGBTQ 2's Canadians thank you for
watching and I'll see you back here
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]